this is a [ __ ] movie i'm gonna
[ __ ] review it welcome to a movie
that says the word [ __ ] so
unnecessarily
[ __ ] many times [ __ ]
we are the millers all right now you
might have heard it's getting pretty
shitty reviews
and i'm here to tell you today as a
movie critiquer
it's a decent movie certainly not great
it has a lot of flaws it's kind of weird
uh when i say weird i mean weird in a
good way it's got weird pacing
throughout
it it really feels like they're they're
doing the comedy beat sheets it feels
like they read a book called save the
cat that book is basically about how to
write a script that'll sell and i really
feel like the four writers that got
together on this film
read that book and we're like yeah we're
gonna we're gonna do it
just like this where it is so apparent
but here's what i like about it
jennifer aniston's body she still looks
so
good look at her
everybody just clap your hands doesn't
her body make you want to do that
i'm telling you right now right now
this is how big my penis is i'm at a
full four inches people and an extra two
for ryan gosling
what's up baby not just her body that's
good her performance is actually really
good too
people take jennifer anderson for
granted i think if you really
look deep into her performances she's
actually a really good actress
back to her body that that is the main
reason to watch this film
shot that's right i said it i said i
said a joke like that you know why
because we are the millers makes jokes
like that
at times where it it just doesn't fit
and jason sedakis man he
he's funny when i first heard he was the
star of this movie i was like can this
guy really carry a movie and you know
what
he plays a really lovable [ __ ] i like
likable [ __ ]
likable [ __ ] are interesting because
they're [ __ ] and in real life we
don't like [ __ ]
but portrayed on the screen we like
[ __ ] [ __ ] are awesome
you know why because there's an [ __ ]
inside all of us and the virgin the 18
year old guy
don't know his [ __ ] name still
haven't looked it up for some reason
basically
um yeah i want to see him in more movies
hollywood pay attention to this dude
he's weird looking but he's really
[ __ ] funny
the other member of the family emma
roberts the horse i'm pretty sure she
got a nose job
because i remember seeing her on the
show before
her nose was not fitting her face too
well she's pretty hot
but um i don't really like her
performance in this film i thought i'd
give him way
better it felt like every line she said
was so prepared like she just
i'm gonna say this line like this
because
i am an actor and i am clearly acting
that's not how you do real acting you
should be more like your aunt
julia roberts who's related to eric
roberts
the coolest actor on the planet i guess
another issue with this movie is i think
it's just way too convenient any danger
or peril situation
there's there's just something
convenient that happens
to help them escape that's where the
writing can get weak when you put
characters in a situation where you go
how are they going to get out of this
instead they have hey something from the
outside of life
just come in here and save the day for
some reason cause some type of
destruction to distract
or take care of the bad guys for
yourselves and it seems like it tries to
be offensive they have a lot of sucking
dick jokes
that's my thing they clearly watched my
show
and were like we need to do a lot of
sucking dick jokes but you know what
if this film had a dick i would not suck
it but here's what i will say
if this cast this oh my god
if this cast all shared one penis
yeah i would suck that because this cast
saves this movie so at the end of the
day
the film is okay enough let me get
straight to the point here
all in all i do have to say we are the
millers
got it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for we are the millers why
don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
me
what would you do with jennifer
aniston's boobs and if you want to
follow me on twitter you can click the
link right here
see that there's magic magic
it's actually called the youtube
annotation but i call it magic and if
you want to see a more in-depth review
of we are the millers because for some
reason you really want to know
the deep parts of we are the millers go
ahead and check out my show called
reasons to see
that i do with my buddy jerry we are the
movie critics is what i like to say
because it's in reference to we are the
pillars last but not least if you want
to get updated every time one of my
reviews is out
go ahead and click on this button by my
penis to subscribe
yes this penis it's waiting
it is waiting for a special somebody
jennifer aniston and just like she says
in the movies
anal no way that's emma roberts